If we look at either side of this equation,
we can figure out what points it corresponds to.
Let's start off by remembering what this equation is saying.
If we look at either side of this equation, we can translate each side into a point
that lies on the graph of an odd function.
This is part of the beauty of using function notation.
f(-x) is the y value of a point.
And it also tells us what the x value of that point is.
This left side means then that we have the point negative x comma, let's call it y for a y coordinate.
And the right side has x as its x coordinate since that's the input.
And then its y coordinate, f(x), is just the negative version of this y coordinate.
Now here's where it gets a little bit tricky.
I didn't tell you that either of these points lies on the graph. I told you that point (x,y) lies on the graph.
What's the difference between this point and this point, though?
Well, here we have negative x and then we have positive x.
And here we have positive y and negative y.
So it looks like for each coordinate, the only thing that has changed is the sign.
If we do that to this point, then what we get is (-x,-y).
So that's your answer,
this is another point that lies in the curve.